optim care lung and allergy Care the
sponsors of this segment are giving us a
head start on healthy long month Rocky
spoke to a doctor and the American Lung
Association to learn more
Dr Lanford you're with Autumn Care and
Lisa you're with American Lung
Association right here in Nevada so it's
really important that we talk about
healthy lung month which is coming up in
October so Dr Lampert let's start with
you obviously I think the first and
foremost number one rule is don't smoke
right that is correct you want to avoid
smoking because it's the commonest cause
of both lung cancer and COPD and or
emphysema which also includes chronic
bronchitis over time cigarette smoke
destroys lung tissue and may trigger
changes that can grow into cancer if you
smoke it is never too late to benefit
from quitting quitting Now is better
than not quitting at all secondhand
smoke chemicals in the home and
workplace as well as radon could all
cause and worsen lung disease
please make your home and car smoke-free
environments consider testing your home
for a radon if you're worried about
radon exposure and talk to your
healthcare provider if you are worried
that something in your home school or
workplace environment may be making you
sick and are there any
should be concerned
yes there are you want to avoid
infection cold or other respiratory
infections particularly covert can be
very serious to your health
there are several things that you can do
to protect yourself
wash your hands often with soap and
water use a mask if need be avoid crowds
doing the cold and flu season
good oral hygiene is also important to
protect you from germs in your mouth
which can lead to infections so be sure
to brush your teeth at least twice daily
and see your dentist every six months
you need to get vaccinated every year
for influenza and there's a new vaccine
out for covert and we do recommend that
you get it as well now Lisa let's bring
you in why is talking about lung health
so important
um it really comes down to the American
Lung association's motto if you can't
breathe nothing else really matters and
by far too many children and adults
battle for breath every day from
diseases such as asthma COPD as well as
lung cancer now what can people who have
relatives with lung disease do so you
definitely want to take a look at say
bythescan.org and you know see where
your chances stand
um and then I would suggest anyone who
wants to support lung disease or learn
more about lung Health you can get
involved in your local American language
Association right here in town and in
fact if you're looking to get involved
into something sooner rather than later
our lung Force walk is coming up
November 5th it's at Cornerstone Park
and it's a great introduction so you can
see how the American Lung Association
Works their fundraisers you can meet the
volunteers and see the resources that's
available it's a free event and you can
attend
um or learn more about it at
lungforce.org forward slash Las Vegas
it's just a really fun Community event
we we welcome everybody in the community
thank you Optum care lung and Allergy
care for sponsoring this segment for
more information call
702-724-8844 or visit lung and
allergy.com